It is hot right now. Genuinely,
historically, record-breakingly hot. And
if you are sitting in a room somewhere
watching this and it's uncomfortable,
you probably have a fan running. Maybe
you even have two.
But here's something that nobody tells
you. Under the right conditions, that
fan is making things worse.
Not a little worse, potentially fatally
worse. Blowing hot air across your skin
when the temperature crosses a certain
threshold doesn't cool you down. It
speeds up the process, and that'll kill
you.
And right now, in parts of this planet,
those conditions already exist. This is
the story of wet-bulb temperature, a
number most people have never heard of.
The threshold the human body cannot
negotiate with, and a climate reality
that is arriving faster than almost
anyone expected. But to understand why,
you first need to understand what your
body is actually doing when it's hot.
And to understand why a fan can kill
you, you first need to understand how
your body cools itself.
Because most people think the answer is
sweating. It's not.
Not exactly.
Sweating is just the delivery system.
The actual cooling mechanism is
evaporation. When sweat sits on your
skin and evaporates, turning liquid into
vapor, it carries away energy with it.
Thermal energy, heat. That's the process
your body is depending on every single
second when you're hot. Without
evaporation, sweat is just wet. It does
nothing. This is why humid days feel so
much worse than dry ones at the same
temperature. In dry air, sweat
evaporates quickly. You might not even
notice you're sweating because it's gone
before it builds up. In humid air, on
the other hand, the atmosphere is
already packed with moisture, and
evaporation slows right down. You feel
drenched. You feel like the heat is
suffocating you because in a very real
sense, your cooling system is being
limited. Your body produces heat
constantly, just from being alive, from
your heart beating to your cells burning
fuel. At rest, you're generating roughly
80 watts of heat. Do anything physical,
and that number climbs fast. Exercise,
and you can hit 6, 7, 800 watts. And all
of that heat has to go somewhere.
Evaporation is the primary exit route.
And when that exit route closes,
something has to give. And scientists
found a way to measure exactly when that
system starts to fail. It's called wet
bulb temperature. Most people have never
even heard of it. Meteorologists have
been measuring this problem for over 200
years using something called a wet bulb
thermometer. It's almost comically
simple. You take a regular thermometer,
wrap its tip in a damp cloth, and expose
it to the air. As water evaporates from
the cloth, it cools down the
thermometer.
The reading you get, the wet bulb
temperature, tells you exactly how
efficiently evaporation is working in
that moment. In dry air, the wet bulb
temperature is much lower than the
actual air temperature, because the
water evaporates easily, and it cools
the thermometer significantly. In humid
air, that gap closes. The wet bulb
temperature creeps toward the actual air
temperature, and if the air becomes
fully saturated, 100% humidity, there's
no evaporation at all. The wet bulb
temperature and the air temperature
become identical. And this number, the
wet bulb temperature, is arguably one of
the most important climate metrics that
most people have never even heard of.
Because it doesn't just tell you how hot
it is, it tells you how hot your body
experiences the heat. It tells you
whether your cooling system can function
or not.
And there is a specific wet bulb
temperature beyond which the human body
simply cannot cope. So, what is that
number? And what does it actually mean
for your body?
35°C
wet bulb.
That is the threshold. Above it, the
physics stop working in your favor. Your
body temperature is approximately 37°.
For heat to leave your body into the
surrounding air, the surrounding air
needs to be able to accept it. At wet
bulb temperature of 35°, the air is so
hot and so saturated with moisture that
evaporation from your skin becomes
essentially zero. Your body keeps
generating heat. It keeps trying to
sweat, but there is nowhere for the heat
or the sweat to go. Core temperatures
begin to rise. And unlike a fever, where
the body deliberately rises the
temperature of the body to fight
infection, that rise is uncontrolled.
Heatstroke, organ failure, and
eventually death.
And this is where the fan comes in. At
moderate temperatures, a fan helps by
moving air across your skin and
accelerating evaporation. That's the
whole point of a fan. But when the air
temperature rises above your skin
temperature, roughly 35°, a fan stops
helping with evaporation and starts
doing something else. It's now blowing
air that is hotter than you onto your
skin. You are essentially absorbing heat
from the moving air. The fan is now a
convection heater aimed at your body.
Add high humidity to that, close to the
wet bulb threshold, and you have a
worst-case scenario. Evaporation is
already failing. The fan cannot restart
it, but it can increase the rate at
which hot air transfers its heat to you.
Under those conditions, the fan does not
save you. It accelerates the process
that will kill you.
This is not a theoretical concern. This
is documented. Studies have shown that
in elderly people whose cardiovascular
systems struggle to compensate, a fan in
extreme heat and humid conditions
measurably increase core temperatures,
rather than reducing it. Now, here is
the part that should genuinely alarm
you.
Scientists studying historical climate
data believed, until fairly recently,
that a sustained wet-bulb temperature of
35° was essentially unprecedented in the
modern era.
Something to worry about in the future.
A threshold humanity had not yet
crossed.
They were wrong.
A 2020 study published in Science
Advances analyzed decades of weather
station data and had found that the
wet-bulb temperature of 35° or at least
very close to it had already occurred in
South Asia, in the Persian Gulf, in
parts of the American Midwest, and in
the Gulf Coast. These events were short,
hours not days, but they happened. And
they happened more frequently than
anyone had predicted. The Persian Gulf
city of Bandar Mashhar in Iran recorded
a wet-bulb temperature of approximately
34.6°
in 2015. Combined with an air
temperature of 46°.
Conditions that sit at the absolute edge
of human survivability. People live
there. People were outside. And each
year, the frequency of these extreme
heat and humidity events increases.
Parts of South Asia, home to billions of
people, many of whom work outdoors, many
of whom have no access to air
conditioning, are projected to
experience regular sustained wet-bulb
temperatures that cross the survival
threshold within decades, not centuries.
Decades. This isn't a distant problem.
It's an arriving one.
But here's the catch. 35° wet-bulb is
actually the optimistic number. Now,
here's the thing about the 35° wet-bulb
figure. It represents the absolute
physiological limit for a young, healthy
adult at rest in a laboratory under
ideal conditions. Real life isn't that.
Studies suggest that for most people,
accounting for age, health, physical
effort, and whether they have shade or
shelter, dangerous heat stress begins at
wet-bulb temperature closer to 28°.
For elderly people, that number drops
even further. For someone doing manual
labor outdoors, the physical effort
alone means their body is generating far
more heat to shed.
So, the threshold where they start
losing the battle arrives much sooner.
This matters enormously when you look at
who is most at risk. It is not people
sitting in air-conditioned offices
watching the thermometer. It is
agricultural workers in India and
Pakistan. It is construction workers in
the Gulf. It is elderly people in
European apartments during a surprise
heat wave, which is exactly what killed
over 70,000 people across Europe in
2003.
The number 35° wet-bulb is technically
where survival becomes impossible for
anyone. But the range between 28 and 35
is where the majority of heat deaths
actually happen. And we are spending an
increasing amount of time in that range.
So, back to the fan. The reason that a
fan can make you die faster isn't
because fans are dangerous. It's because
the conditions in which fans stop
working and start harming are conditions
that now exist on this planet.
Conditions that are becoming more and
more common, and conditions that most
people have no framework for
understanding because almost nobody
talks about wet-bulb temperature. We
talk about air temperature. We talk
about heat index, feel like
temperatures, and warnings to stay
hydrated. But the actual physical limit,
the number that tells you whether your
body's cooling system can function at
all, rarely makes the news. 35°
wet-bulb, that's the wall.
Below it, your body can fight. Above it,
no amount of water, no amount of shade,
no fan, nothing changes the outcome. The
physics have closed the door. And the
honest, uncomfortable truth is this.
Parts of the world already touching that
wall.
More parts will reach it and billions of
people living in those regions have no
way to get behind the only thing that
reliable works above the threshold.
Air conditioning, which for billions of
people in parts of the earth already
crossing this threshold isn't an option.
Next time it's hot, and right now it is
very hot, and you reach for that fan,
now you know what it can and cannot do
and why sometimes the thing that you
reach for to save yourself is the thing
that makes it worse.